i think we have a good energy here today
because you know what california
finally lifted some restrictions it's
been a
yeah we are now we are now allowed to
get the mail and flee wildfires so
things are really loosening up out here
and and that's just locally i mean on
the national level boy biden
boy he said he's president now you hear
that that's good
uh yeah and he's
reversing everything trump did who
reversed everything obama did it's a
great way we govern this country by
undoing
but he uh like doing some good things
trump had a ban on transgender people
serving in the military
biden undid that but uh to uh
but to avoid confusion now drill
sergeants will no longer say
drop your [ __ ] and grab your socks
that's out because
who knows who even has a cop
and oh and the navy's new policy is
whatever floats your boat that's
also uh this is great we're putting
harriet tubman
on the 20. the 20 bill i
i cannot wait to go into the strip club
and make it rain with 20s and scream
it's all about the tubmans
i'm going to do that as soon as this
pandemic is over i
but harriet tubman under 20. that's
great not a surprise that america
because america has always respected
black women on paper
oh yeah that's right boo first
then think about it and now okay that's
right that's
always boo first it's safe
even when i'm with you but uh over in
the senate the republican senators have
uh listened to this voted against even
holding the impeachment trial
a couple of weeks ago they were all
about maybe we should impeach trump no
no they say no impeachment we don't even
want the trial we're going to acquit him
anyway not even censure but they say it
will go on his permanent record
yes and you know trump have been very
quiet have doesn't that alarm you a
little
it's like in in jaws when the shark went
out to sea for a little while it's like
i think it'll be back so he's down there
in
mar-a-lago and and he's off twitter i
guess that's a lot of it
you know who else is off twitter mike
lindell the my pillow guy
was banned
bad from twitter for uh uh tweeting out
repeated lies about the election being
rigged
which you know i think is is right but
what about the repeated lies about his
pillow being more than just a goddamn
pillow
uh yeah i tell you the republicans they
have a little bit of a
lunatic problem in that party they they
have
people like that and then they have
somebody in congress
actually working in the building
marjorie taylor green we've talked about
it here
on the show she's a freshman
congressperson and uh
she's deleting all her tweets this week
but this were only from like
a couple of years ago that she's liked a
lot of things on social media
about murdering nancy pelosi and has
threatened to do so
how how does that work how do you call
for
murdering nancy pelosi and then you're
working together
what do you say to her when you see her
in the elevator
i love your shoes
when we hang you they're gonna look
great
and kevin mccarthy he's he's the head
guy in the house he
he he's heard about the things that
marjorie taylor green has been saying
and he's like he's very disturbed
he's disturbed she's disturbed he says
he plans to have a conversation with
a conversation uh marjorie we've been
getting some complaints
uh from co-workers that you want to kill
them
i think if you look at your freshman
orientation guide you'll see plainly on
page 16 it says we don't kill our
workers thank you so much for coming in
this is this is the america we're living
in
marjory talley green believes i mean
this she had never met a conspiracy
theory she doesn't
like she believes in something called
frazzle drip i'm not make i couldn't
i out frazzle drip it sounds like
something lil wayne uses to get high
what frazzle drip this is
listen to this this is a real theory
that they have there
uh in the town
that there is a video out there that
shows
hillary clinton cutting the face off a
teenage girl
wearing it like a mask and then drinking
the girl's blood
so that she can obtain a certain
chemical
that gives her special powers
what we hear in beverly hills called the
vampire facial
wow i i i must tell you
maybe i'm just getting old but i
remember when the nuttiest thing
republicans believed in was trickle-down
economics
frazzle drip i'm sorry i am not watching
this video
i'm going to wait till it comes out in
the theater that's where i want to see
it i understand
you